um so I'm so excited to be here today
with Carlos he's a leader I really
admire because he uses his business
Acumen to take on big challenges and
he's done so in his home country of Peru
and Beyond he's built a group of schools
affordable schools called Anova and they
serve 65 about 65,000 students he also
has a group of um he has a chain of
eternity healthcare clinics he's taken
on infrastructure projects in public
private Partnerships among other things
now I have to tell you it's taken me a
couple of years to convince Carlos to
come speak with us here at Ted he's not
really Spotlight guy you're more likely
to find him doing deep research
Undercover Boss style than talking about
his work in the glossy pages of business
magazine not that he doesn't deserve to
be there he really does and so we're so
lucky to have him here with us today to
tell us more about what he's done how
he's done it and what we can learn from
it so thanks for being here Carlos
thanks Corey glad to be
here so let's start with education what
was the problem you saw there so let me
just put it in context and tell you a
little bit about Peru Peru is a middle-
inome country it's right in the middle
of South America on the Pacific coast
and from 1990 to 2010 or actually
2017 we grew our economy at close to 5%
so it's one of the fastest growing
economies in the world and certainly the
fastest in South America at the same
time the poverty rate came down from 55%
to 25% so we were feeling pretty good
about all the things were going on in
Peru and it seemed like there was a
possibility that eventually 25 years
from now we could become a developed
country but there are a lot of hurdles
along the way that we have to overcome
in order to get there and some of them
include the basic things that happen in
most developing countries like education
Healthcare
infrastructure now during the same time
um I remember in about 2007 they did an
assessment of all the public school
teachers and the results were not very
encouraging a very small percentage
passed basic math basic reading
comprehension and in the year 2000 we uh
were r last in the Pisa rankings which
are these rankings for 15-year-old kids
in various countries and 12 years later
we're also dead last so despite all this
growth we had a real issue to improve
our education system and uh so we
decided to to get involved to understand
what was going on because it was obvious
that we could not become a developed
country with having worldclass education
and
Healthcare and and um you said that the
public schools were in rough shape so we
wanted to share a photo of the public
school the state of the public schools
and you were saying it's not just the
way it looks it was what was going on
inside yeah so this is a typical public
school we saw when we started our our
research and you can see it kind of
looks dark outside but what's worse is
what's going on inside kids aren't
learning a low attendance low engagement
and and poor equality and as a result of
these Public Schools a lot of small
informal private schools started popping
up all over the country and they were
just as bad as some of the public
schools and today yeah and they have
catchy names right a here's another one
with a catchy name
and some of you may have gone
there and so when we did our our
undercover kind of Boss research we went
to one of these schools and I remember
going with a couple of colleagues and uh
asking a lot of questions to the person
who gave us the tour she didn't believe
that we were parents with kids looking
to go into those schools but and she was
getting suspicious and asked us to
please leave because she was the
director and also the owner and before
she left we asked her one final question
before we left we asked her one final
question and that is why did you decide
to do a private school and uh her answer
surprised this she said because it's
more profitable than a Chinese food
restaurant now sadly this is a level of
commitment in a lot of these private
schools so we decided it's time to do
something about this not quite the right
motivation um education is so
complicated so when you started this
journey what were your
goals well I didn't know anything about
education except from being a student
and a consumer of it for for many years
so the the first thing I did and this is
true story I watched every Ted Talk on
education and and promise it's not a
plant no and uh then started reaching
out to the different people I thought
were interesting and were doing um
wonderful things there and then I I grew
up partly in California I worked on Wall
Street so I started um looking at my
contact list and I remember an
innovation company that that um when I
grew up in in in California that was
always you know behind a lot of the
product Innovation so I called them up
Ido and with them along with s who we we
were introduced with and some academics
from Berkeley and from from Harvard we
put together a a system to really try to
change education in our country so in
Peru we have 8 million K through 12 kids
and our Target was about uh 1.6 million
of those kids over time which we call
the emerging middle class and what we
co-designed was a system that had four
characteristics the first one uh it had
to be affordable and by affordable I
mean $150 a month for the regular
students and for our scholarship
students $1 a day second it had to have
academic Excellence these are schools
that had to move the needle otherwise it
doesn't really make sense and uh they're
well-designed they're modern they were
safe third we wanted a project that was
scalable not just to build one or two
schools but why not aspired to build
hundreds of schools and perhaps cross
borders and go to other countries and
fourth we thought it was very important
that the schools be
sustainable and sustainable is kind of
our code word for
profitable yeah so profitability let's
talk a little bit about that why is that
so important because we talked about the
woman in the Chinese restaurant and that
she didn't seem properly motivated so
why for you is profitability so
important I think it's very important
because that way we can keep building
more more schools and we can go across
borders and and and and keep this
project going and you know it's very
ambitious uh it's very ambitious for the
teachers
and so I imagine someday in in some
neighboring country you know Mom and Dad
having a conversation about where
they're send where they to send their
kids to school and maybe one of the
parents say hey what about that school
with the peruvians are teaching so
imagine that going from last in
education in the world to being the
teachers of our region that would do so
much to the self-esteem of our country
per real all right so that goes back to
what you were saying about
sustainability profitability for you
equals
sustainability um so there must be some
tradeoffs that you're making to make
these schools reach profitability what
are some of those trade-offs sure when
you when you start kind of with a fixed
you know price that you can charge
there's you can't do everything so
sometimes our students have to share
tablets and we don't have swimming pools
but we have very nice spaces where kids
can learn they can
collaborate um we use a blended learning
model which is solo learning and
classroom learning this is a an image of
one of our schools and the next is an
image of our rockar math teacher from
middle school Salan it's a a funny story
when Sal came to visit us in Peru many
years ago when we're just starting out
he he came to our our math lab where we
have 60 kids and one monitor looking and
helping the kids that that need help and
as I was talking to S and a couple of
other people with him and as you know he
never appears in his videos it's just
his voice and and one of the young kids
uh said hey that sounds like Shan is
that is that s and before you knew it
word got around a big huge line of all
these kids asking s for his autograph no
Hitler math
teacher it's a really wonderful story a
nice rockar to have sto by um so let's
shift gears a little towards healthc
care what what did you want to do there
and what have you done in that space so
healthc care was as broken as the
education system maybe the slight
difference is in education you have to
have a real sense of urgency otherwise
you miss the entire generation and in
healthcare
we are fairly lucky that we still have a
young population so perhaps we have a
little more time to to go through this
but you know our Healthcare System um is
a universal healthcare 8 million
informal workers um have that for the
government and then 4 million pay a tax
of the formal economy that's slightly
better but this is a typical picture you
make a long
line sometimes it's hours there's a lot
of informal just like the the private
schools and and they'll offer two for
one medical procedures you know it's
it's it's kind of you know not friend
exactly it's not not not you know not
good quality um so again we teamed up
with Ido and a lot of different
institutions to design something for the
emerging middle class um and um you know
the the first the first call in Peru
ises
so if you're sick you go to the pharmacy
first because you you waste a whole day
and you really can't afford to to leave
work for a day and so right around the
time we started Inova we got involved in
in in in buying a small chain of
pharmacies that today has
2,300 um locations throughout the entire
country including the most remote areas
you can imagine in the Amazon where you
have to go in canoes and and ships to
get there and and as an extension of
that we we also developed a clinic
called Aviva where we give good quality
a about 40 to 60 beds in each one of our
clinics um and uh we're focusing on the
most important part uh of life which is
birth a this particular clinic in Lima
had the most births of the entire
country last year um and uh so now we
have an alternative to give good health
care to the emerging middle
class now another thing you've dipped
your toe into in pretty big ways
infrastructure and that's a whole
different kind of project and you did it
through a public private partnership can
you talk a little bit about how that
came about and how it worked so years
ago I remember going to adipa which is
the second largest city in Peru with my
father and my grandfather and um in that
visit hearing about a bridge that was
going to be built years later I went
back and I heard about the bridge again
and it turns out that this bridge has
been on the planning board for over 50
years and it never got done know it was
because this party was in power that
whatever the reason it just didn't get
done so a few years ago the government
came up with a very clever plan it's
called projects for taxes and what that
does is it allows companies to use up
the 30% of the taxes they pay instead of
paying it to the central government to
use it for project s that the community
needs they have to be peer proofed for
the by the government but then you you
you kind of do it yourself so we teamed
up with the largest beer company in puru
and one of the large mining companies
and together um we put $100 million of
the taxes we would have paid to the
central government and we built this
bridge and which uh connects you know
one side of the city to the other it was
done on time it's an on budget no
corruption no drama the bridge is still
standing and and uh now you know
thousands of people every single day use
this bridge and as a result improve the
quality of their life this is a very
good example of how private Public
Partnerships can work and what we've
done in our group is we've set a goal to
have an iconic project like that bridge
you just saw in every one of the 25
States across Peru
a so far we've completed five in five
different states so we have 20 to go but
we're excited about that I I when I read
about that I thought that was such an
interesting project and an interesting
partnership um so a lot of the
businesses you've started and your
projects are focused on the middle class
so why are you so focused on that
particular segment of the population so
the middle class for the last couple of
decades has been the fastest growing
segment of the country
it was in a way low hanging fruit and a
lot of services were unmet and um so we
we tried to develop answers for those
and it was also a a way to scale fast
because a lot of the emerging middle
class is in urban settings um so you can
actually um go to Zero from zero to
relevance relatively fast it what we're
working on now is what we call the next
Frontier which is rural Peru which is a
still a big part of the population and
all the cities in our country that have
20,000 or less people but really the
reason we got involved in areas like
education and Healthcare is that you
know the government wasn't delivering if
you're familiar with Peru um you know
what's been going on we've had six
presidents in six years now the last
president before the current one um had
a so many cabinet changes that on
average every five days we'd have a new
cabinet minister so ask yourself if
you're running an
organization
um you can't get even through the
weekend maybe Monday he's here Friday
they're gone and so it's very very hard
to to get things accomplished from the
government side so what should we do
should we wait for that Batman president
to show up or should we get involved and
have to admit that for many years I
would attend conferences and would do
what a lot of people do the golf clap
and then go back to your work and say
yeah I'd like to help but you know and
then the next year another golf clap and
kind of the same thing and but we really
believe that the private sector has a
very important role it's 80% of the
economy in our country and we can really
push the leaders along to take on the
most difficult the most challenging
problems in the country because
education takes 20 25 years or more to
solve a a political term may be only
four or five years and so I think uh we
have a more staying power and and we
don't pretend to run the whole education
system or to educate the 8 million kids
that that go to
schools but if we do our job correctly
maybe we can put it up at the top with
the agenda maybe we can show how it can
be done we can continue to partner with
the government and together as a result
make a better country yeah I mean a lot
of the things you've done you've stepped
in where government has fallen short do
you feel like you're letting them off
the hook though or do you feel that
they're responding to this I would say
it's the opposite we're putting pressure
to get these things resolved and I
believe that uh um you know by showing
what can be done um you know perhaps we
can
Inspire them to work together not just
with us but with all the other fine
companies that we have in our country
that that do worldclass things and but
we can't just fold our hands and wait
and and hope that you know the Savior
someday comes and helps us and uh I I I
think that's what's behind all these
projects now there was um one more
picture you wanted me to share with the
audience of the pro test in Peru why did
you want me to share this with them this
is a horrible picture it's horrible for
a number of reasons it hurts our tourism
the image of the country Etc but what
makes me really sad about this picture
and this happened not too long ago a few
weeks ago is it's provian against
provian and I think we both want the
same things we want a better life we
want opportunity we have the ability to
reach our our dreams and go as far as we
can go and uh so when I see this um you
know I wonder is this just Peru or can
this happen in other communities and how
can we stop this from happening and so I
have some suggestions the the first one
is find out what are the most difficult
challenges in your community in your
country and try to understand them get
involved put a sense of urgency raise
your hand not
someday make someday
today second is seek out help most
likely the problems been solved
somewhere else and you can add to that
and continue to to build and uh know the
last thing is have a mindset where
you're trying to make the pie
bigger and even if you come from the
private sector I guarantee you if you
focus on making the pie bigger for your
country
you'll do well yourself our objective is
to make Peru the best place to raise a
family in Latin America our long-term
objective is to push Peru to become a
developed country and that's really hard
and then it comes to
execution and this is where we lose a
lot of that impetus a lot of that let's
get it done because it's hard and uh
what we found out is that when you have
a big challenge many times you'll say
yes but and that but follows lots and
lots of excuses right in Peru in Spanish
it's C poo is about p e r o so we
decided to make it a little easier and
why not change that o to the U and wake
up every morning and say see
Peru
well I think you can see why I admire
this
guy um thank you so much Carlos for all
that you've shared with us and I think
we all have a lot of work to do so thank
you thank you
Corey